l'interdiction pour les mineurs de
porter dans l'espace public tout signe
religieux ostensible aurait pu
constituer un signal fort envoyé à notre
jeunesse
elle aurait pu voir une garantie pour la
préservation de son insouciance de sa
liberté
dans quelle mesure une république laïque
peut être toléré que des enfants
manifestent des signes religieux au su
et au vu de tout le monde
ce n'est pas aux parents d'imposer des
dormeurs enfants aussi l'essentiel qui
existe des espaces protecteur pour ce
dernier vecteur d'émancipation le
présent amendement visant à interdire
dans l'espace public le port de signes
ou de tenues par des mineurs manifestant
ostensiblement une appartenance
religieuse dans cette perspective il est
indispensable d'empêcher tout moyen
d'infériorité l'enfant et notamment la
jeune fille au travers d'un habit ou des
vêtements qu'on lui impose
[Musique]